[Music]
unfortunately tonight the lawless left
continues to sow hate division more
attacks on the military and law
enforcement as the National Guard in
Utah confirmed that they were kicked out
of their DC hotel why by the radical DC
mayor earlier this week who at the same
time was using city resources to paint a
black lives matter mural leading to the
White House wasn't that the group maybe
my memory is faulty well what do we want
dead cops when do we want them now
hmm pigs in a blanket fry em like bacon
I just don't quite remember now
President Trump earlier today tweeted
well mayor Bowser is grossly incompetent
no way qualified to be running an
important city like Washington DC now if
the great men and women of the National
Guard didn't step forward well she would
have looked no better than her
counterpart mayor in Minneapolis here
with reaction the host of the Rubin
report David Rubin Dave you talked a lot
about freedom of speech and I call it
you know we've got you know literally
groupthink mob media and I believe that
you had all right voxcom they're not
exactly Sean Hannity or Dave Rubin fans
but you know one writer said it's a bad
idea abolishing the police he had to
walk that back we saw you know nobody's
loves a city more than drew brees for
crying out loud and and he made his
comments about kneeling he's allowed to
have his opinion we saw what happened
there
and now the NFL commissioners weighing
in I just like free open exchange of
ideas and ideals and that includes
people that beat the living hell out of
me which happens regularly I accept it
that's part of the great tradition of
this country absolutely Sean and by the
way the chickens are coming home to
roost so it's nice to see a couple New
York Times or Vox or BuzzFeed people
coming around and going oh maybe the
police are decent or maybe law and order
is a decent thing maybe the Constitution
and America they ain't that bad but it's
a little too late right because these
are the people
that have been trying to cancel you for
years when you talk about black crime in
Chicago for example where just this past
weekend I think something like 19 people
black people were killed I mean crazy
statistics but of course we should all
be for free speech in the open exchange
of ideas but what's happening here you
know I'm in LA right now the the
progressive mayors and governors they
want this chaos because it gives them an
excuse to use more power and then they
feel that then proves that the whole
system is broken but a guy like drew
brees who have nothing but respect for
he made a really terrible mistake
by apologizing for what he believed and
what was true because once you bend the
need of these people which we're
watching so many people do right now my
mayor Eric Garcetti
was on his knees just a day or two ago
in front of protesters once you bend the
knee you must live down there forever
they will keep you their foot on your
throat and I would much rather live as a
free man and be hated then then bow to
people who want to control me if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell